what does your current morning routine
look like I want the full monty but for
Monty all right well interrupt me if I
tend to write a hole too much no but I
yeah I usually you know wake up without
an alarm unless I got to catch a flight
or something like that I just find I
naturally tend to wake sometime around
like it just like 5:45 6:15 somewhere in
there and I just find that that you know
waking naturally I'm not opposed to some
of these devices you know like I I sleep
on one of these chilly pad things that
keeps your body cool or you're asleep
which is great for enhancing your deep
sleep and there's apparently a function
on it where you can activate it to
circulate more warm water to gradually
wake you I don't use that function I'm
nervous that I might just pee my pants
when that warm water turns on and then I
have one of those sunrise alarm clocks
for when I do got to set the alarm on
they just kind of gradually bleed Sun
into your room so you wake a lot more
slowly which i think is just wonderful
for not you know ripping you out of a
deep sleep cycle if you happen to be one
in one in the in the morning
and so yeah I wake I roll over and I do
some gratitude journaling for the first
few minutes of the day I write down one
thing I'm grateful for I write down a
one person who I can help that day
whether it's like you know calling my
mom or or you know helping the neighbor
move something or or even just like you
know giving a bottle of wine to somebody
who I know might need a smile that day
and you know I I just really like that
others facing type of mentality to start
today because I figure if I you know if
I'm writing down one person I can help
each day that's 365 you know good things
I might do during the course of a year
so I do that and then I write down also
any any insights that I had from my my
dream cycles earlier in the night or you
know any just little encouraging words
to myself that I I don't want to act on
during the day and then I get out of bed
I'm kind of into into the Ayurvedic
concepts in terms of the morning routine
so I do a quick tongue scrape which
takes just a few seconds with a little
copper tongue scraper what's the logic
behind that back of the tongue to the
front of the tongue just helps to click
to clean out some bacteria in the mouth
that accumulates during a night of sleep
and then I also do oil pulling so I use
coconut oil blended with some essential
oils like clove and peppermint and swish
that around in the mouth
well I'm tuned around during the day you
know taking a pee and getting things
ready for the day and that's also a
really really great oral hygiene tactic
again barred from Ayurvedic medicine and
so I then go downstairs into the kitchen
and if I've woken pretty early or if I
have been traveling a lot and I'm trying
to kind of like reset my circadian
rhythm to whatever time zone that I
happen to be in I'll usually wear those
blue light blocking glasses that people
wear at night
I'll wear those in the morning because I
find that that reddish orange lens Kylie
does a good job simulating sunrise so if
I'm flipping on lights in the kitchen or
glancing at my phone or open to the
computer anything it's a little bit more
of a gentle way to wake up kind of that
same concept of not waking with an alarm
clock wearing these blue light blocking
glasses in the morning kind of gives you
that really kind of sunrise desk feel in
the morning because my lazy ass is not
gonna be other than the sun's rising so
what's the what's the brand of sunrise
glasses you use I use the ones made by
raw optics I you know they the owner of
that company Matt maruka he's a friend
of mine he's just he's so steeped in
light research and he's constantly
retooling the lenses to block out
specific wavelengths of light and a lot
of these blue light blocking companies
they know how to make a quick buck and
although import cheap lenses from you
know India or China or whatever and then
mark up the price it's all on Amazon and
he's actually doing a really good job
with his lens technology and so I I used
the raw optics brand there's a few of
the good ones out there I think what's
the company blanking on their name blue
blue blockers I think they do a pretty
good job and there's a there's a couple
others out there but I use the raw true
dark true dark is another one does a
good job so use these these raw red
lenses and usually I'll take them off
typically after I've been up for about
20 30 minutes or so so again I'm just
kind of easing
easing from a light standpoint my body
into the day and then once I've spat out
that coconut oil I kind of rinse my
mouth out because you don't want to
swallow it because it's just like it's
accumulating bacteria and stuff in your
mouth so it's it's it's just like
cleaning you want to spit it out so I
split out in the trash can so I don't
clog the toilets with oil I learned that
lesson the hard way
don't put it in a toilet or a sink it
clogs the plumbing so you actually spit
your oil into trashcan rinse out your
mouth then I have a big glass mason jar
full of goodies so I I make myself a big
glass mason jar with some hydrogen
tablets in it because hydrogen there's a
lot of good research from the molecular
hydrogen foundation on the on hydrogen
for at anti-inflammatory and selective
antioxidant properties and the you know
I'm convinced by the research enough to
do a big glass mason jar of that at both
the beginning and the end of the day but
at the beginning of the day I put
minerals into that so typically like a
pinch of a really good salt like Celtic
salt or another one I've been using of
late are these these minerals that are
harvested from these l.joe blooms and
it's it's got like 80 plus minerals and
it's called Kington qu int o N and so
like a like a hypertonic plasma so I put
some of that in the water along with the
hydrogen and then I do a two to one
ratio of vitamin C and baking soda
there's a really great book that delves
into all the science of vitamin C in
baking soda called forbidden healing and
I I was I was so convinced after reading
that book about some of the effects on
everything from from a mild change in pH
to an increase in in some immune factor
compounds to just just the overall
physiological effect of both vitamin C
and baking soda that I just have right
there in the pantry bulk ascorbic acid
and uh and then just Arm and Hammer
baking soda which is natural aluminum
free and so I got baking soda
I got vitamin C I got hydrogen water I
got minerals all in this big glass mason
jar water
yeah and I just sucked that down that's
kind of my tonic and sometimes we'll
throw a little apple cider vinegar in
there as well because that is a really
nice insulin sensitizing in fact at the
beginning
day and lens even more alkalinity to the
drink so so I have that and then I I put
on a pot of hot water or I start the
coffee and I'll go back and forth some
mornings I do coffee and then just
because I don't want my adenosine
receptors to to get too too insensitive
right yeah which makes me sleep till
later on the day I don't do coffee every
day because I don't want to I don't want
to to to create a scenario in which I'm
insensitive to adenosine later on in the
day and can't fall asleep because even
if even if you metabolize caffeine
really well if you're a fast coffee
oxidizer and even if you you're not
having a cup of coffee afternoon just
frequent regular use of coffee without
breaks builds up so much of these
identity and receive Druce it just gets
harder and harder as months go on to
fall asleep at night yeah so so what I
do is I'll either do coffee or the other
one that I'll do is is cacao T which is
lowering coffee or lowering caffeine but
it has like theobromine and some
dopamine precursors and it has this real
good kind of picked me up feel-good
effect
nice some people like your of amante for
that but your Bonacci makes me a little
jittery and I like the way cacao makes
me feel instead so I'll typically blend
that with chaga which is which is
wonderful it's it's it's chock full of
melanin chaga is which can actually
interact with sunlight to to kick off
electrons and produce some free ATP so
any photons of light will interact with
things like melon in chlorophyll would
be another example methylene blue which
is marketed now's a nootropic that's
another example but because I I'll tell
you in a second I go down to the office
and I do some red light therapy and like
I like getting a little melanin or
chlorophyll or methylene blue in my
system before I go do the red light
therapy and blending this chaga with
some cacao or doing the coffee but that
chocolate the cacao is really great if
you're doing like red light therapy in
the morning just prime them Prime's you
for that red light right just before we
move on the yeah you basically produce
an extra ATP you were talking about ways
to assure that your adenosine receptors
don't get down regulated by
basing your coffee use what have you
found to be an optimal way to pulse that
every other day three times a week twice
a week
what well in the book I talk about how
one tactic for people who just want to
drink coffee every morning you just do
coffee for three weeks and then twist to
a really switch to a good decaf like
Swiss water process decaf or co2
extraction decaf for about a week takes
around six to eight days to reset those
adenosine receptors but if I'm just kind
of doing it naturally I just listen to
my body basically if I wake up and I
don't feel a need for little extra
caffeine I just don't have coffee I did
the choc so it typically comes out to
about uh two or three mornings of the
week is the chaga in the cacao and the
other mornings it's just a good cup of
organic coffee cut you just just organic
black coffee I don't do any calories
just because I don't want to take myself
out of a fasted state in the morning so
no ml MCT oil or butter or anything like
that just just black coffee and then on
well well the hot water is going for the
cacao tea or the chaga or the coffee's
brewing I spend 10 to 15 minutes just
doing body work like foam rolling
sometimes it's like the little vibrating
balls sometimes lacrosse balls but I
just I take 10-15 minutes every morning
do deep tissue work so whether or not I
get a massage I try to get a massage
once a week even if I don't you know I
figured by the end of the week I'm
getting a good 75 to 90 minutes of
really good deep tissue work and I just
find it Prime's my body for the day a
lot of times I combined it with some
breath work a little bit of inversion so
I'll hang from an inversion table or
from some from like some gravity boots
but it's kind of like my non-negotiable
me time for like 15 minutes in the
morning I'll usually listen to like a
sermon or a really good spiritual
podcast while I'm doing that just to
start off my day on a really positive
note and and then once I've done all
that I'll grab the coffee or the tea and
I'll head down to my office and I'll
generally spend about a half hour going
through typically like research articles
science some of the feeds that I follow
in in you know like like health exercise
science nutrition science
some some different Twitter feeds of
research journals I just really like to
learn at the beginning the day I found
my body just soaks up it feels really
prime to learn so I'm typically not
doing emails or or you know social media
and stuff at that time I just kind of
soak up some knowledge at the beginning
of the day well I'm having my coffee or
my tea and while I'm doing that I use
red light therapy so I've got these big
these juvie annals in my office that I
flip on so as I'm standing there going
through all the research I'm just bathed
in red light I take off all my clothes
and I just do like naked red light
therapy full-body and that's for like
twenty to thirty minutes it's amazing
you nitric oxide release it it
stimulates mitochondrial production of
ATP it's just this this complete
feel-good effect it's and it's also very
similar to to sunrise again so I'm
getting that big red light dose in the
morning which is great for circadian
rhythm and you know I like my office to
be just like this total Zen den so you
know I've got essential oils kind of
getting diffused into the air I got that
red light therapy I've got a little
grounding mat that I stand on so it's as
though I were outside kind of sucking up
some negative ions from the surface of
the earth same thing from standing in
that my office I get the the same effect
so so that's just kind of my me time in
the morning and I finish up all that and
you'll you'll find if you guys use that
tactic of baking soda with that glass
mason jar after about 45 minutes that
baking soda kicks in and you just go
have this awesome awesome dump so I flip
off the red lights after about a
half-hour and you know I just I can tell
right away you feel the stomach gurgling
little bit it's like all right ready to
go and go upstairs and just house have
an amazing amazing amazing bowel
movement and then you know by then its
hits typically around you know like 7:45
to 8:15 in the morning and I usually
before I jump into the rest of the day
you know and kind of start working
everything or have some breakfast I like
to do some kind of like a morning some
kind of morning protocol that makes me
feel really good I don't like to hit the
weights hard or do like a big
I intensity interval training session in
the morning so usually for me it's
either about a 20 or 30 minute walk in
the sunshine or a 20 or 30 minutes on a
session so this would be after I go to
the bathroom yeah you know I'll do you
like a sauna plus a cold soak you know
20 to 30 minutes in the sauna just the
deep sweat again I'll put essential oils
in the sauna sometimes I'll put on like
a topical rub like you these topical
muscle creams that have things like you
know cayenne and menthol and black
pepper because you just sweat buckets I
found if you if you smear some stuff
over your skin yeah before we get into
the sauna I'm using one called prototype
8x8 EP science right now I'll just like
smiling on my arms on my legs you know
put some some really good uplifting
essential oils in there like rosemary or
cinnamon or something that's really kind
of like stimulating to the brain to get
me all charged up for the workday and do
the sauna
so I'm sweating really hard then go
don't go jump in the cold pool or take
the cold shower for about three or four
minutes and I'm either doing that or
just like a long walk in the sunshine
and so do all that and then you know I
own a company called kion and we always
have a call every morning at 9:45 so I
gotta be done showered you know ready
for the day you know spend a little time
with the kids and say good morning to
them and hear about how they're gonna
spend their day they're homeschooled so
they're at home with me all day anyway
so I just gotta check in with them make
sure they're all set for the day and
checking with my wife make sure she's
all set for the day and then I just make
myself a a giant superfood smoothie oh
I'm getting ready for that call with my
team and that you know the smoothie just
changes everyday but typically it's
things like you know for my base I just
use ice and then I'll put some stevia in
there or some monk fruit in there for a
sweetener and then I just love to toss a
bunch a bunch of great stuff in there so
for my liquid I'll usually use bone
broth or kefir or sometimes coconut milk
I make my own yogurt at home usually
using coconut milk or goat's milk as a
base so I'll put some yogurt in there
and then typically a few scoops or
something like your greens I'll put some
collagen in there squeeze them
or some kind of vitamin C in there and
then I I just blend all that up if I
want a little more creaminess I'll put
like half an avocado in there sometimes
for a little bit of extra greens you
know I grow sprouts at home so I'll put
some sprouts in there and then I'll top
it with just a bunch of goodies like
spirulina like after I've blended it
I'll top it with like spirulina coconut
flakes cacao nibs but I blend the
smoothie really thick so I basically
like eat it out of a bowl almost like an
eyeball with all these negative roots oh
yeah it's amazing it's so good it's like
the highlight of my day
I'm thinking about that one doing my son
or my walk I'm already thinking about
that amazing amazing superfood Bowl I'm
gonna make it home and so I typically
I'll eat that while I'm on the call with
my team just chatting with my team you
know hearing about where everybody's
gonna be up to for the day and just
touching base with with the whole squad
because I'm running my company virtually
for the most part because our offices
are in Boulder but I'm up in uh
Washington State and they're down you
know most of my teams is down kind of
around Colorado so I I do that call and
then after that from about 10:00 until
around 2:00 or 2:30 I just you know no
push notifications no no Twitter no
Facebook no social media I just work
like a horse with blinders on for the
next four or five hours you know comment
that deep work concepts you know like
counting Newports book where I'm just
you know whether I'm writing or working
on a book or a series of articles or
shooting videos doing content doing
consults with my clients or people who
have hired me to go over their nutrition
or their workout plans with them or
their you know their lab work their
blood work sometimes you know I advise a
lot of companies in the health and
fitness space so sometimes it's advisory
calls for different businesses you know
ever every day kind of varies but yeah
but for me that kind of like 10:00 to
2:00 or 2:30 slot is just deep work time
just crush the day during that time
hyper productive and I take breaks about
every you know it depends on on this
style of work that move every 30 or 60
minutes I'll take breaks and you know do
some pull-ups do some kettlebell swings
you know
jump up and down on a trampoline I just
like to take little breaks just to keep
my body moving during those those you
know four or five hours of work
[Music]
you